[موسيقى]
كما مات الرب كنت مألوفا
سأأخذ أيضًا الاسم الأول ، اسمي بيب
سأدعوه جوزيف لا أعرف ما هو
يجب أن تكون غرفة السيد جوزيف
كل هذا يجب أن يكون كل هؤلاء
غدا في الساعة 8:45 نلتقي هنا
في الميدان خارج الميدان وفاز
فاز طوال العام
طوال هذا الموسم وفي
المستقبل ما سوف يعطيه له
أبطال معينون خارج الميدان
خذها إلى المنزل واستمتع بها تمامًا
والاخر سنلعب احيانا سأفوز
أحيانًا أخسر أو نفوز أو نخسر
عادة يفوز لأنها له
التاريخ إذا كنت تدعمنا في بعض الأحيان نحن
نحن نقبل انتصارات أصغر
التي نرجوا الإعجاب بها
عالم لسنا فيه كثيرًا
فخور في هذه الغرفة فهو سخيف
الرئيس ، السيد اللعين هو من يعرف أكثر
العالم ولا اريد المنافسة ولا حتى
لحظة أتذكر فقط أننا كنا
اربع سنوات معا
[موسيقى]